that's what i'm taking from this yeah  fiona of  shameless over here just  jesus christ  oh forget it  i love it so much  i love it so much dude it's hilarious if  you're in jail you have a  ring of people following you that you  beat up  what a [ __ ] i would have lost my mind  not terrifying oh i would have lost my  [ __ ] i probably would have just died  right there  i probably would have died from fright  right then and they're like oh  i'm like they're plotting on me they're  trying to [ __ ] kill me because i  think i'm dying and he's trying to  convince me that i'm not dying oh so you  think he poised me  oh you're my friend oh you want to hang  out my friend more  is trying to kill me i don't want to  build goals with you i want to  accomplish things with you and  we're always going to support each other  no matter what we're going to go through  hard times we know that we accept that  but our goal in life is to push always  push forward push forward  and make [ __ ] happen